hello everybody and welcome to part 2
part 2 Wow I got that wrong
part 7 of nightmare house - oh man this
games getting to me alright I got my
squad here we're ready to go all this
looks like a kill room oh this is where
they die is where they die oh boy oh boy
here comes oh no he's gotta be here
somewhere
oh boy oh no oh no he's dying he's dead
he's gone oh he's so dead the health
workers there - look
oh man oh man not good not good not good
not good
nice move Oh what what the hell oh no oh
no what is Oh what what is that oh my
goodness oh my goodness I am open oh wow
that is creepy
oh it flashlight don't fail me now
oh man
that one's not a spider but wow look at
those
ma'am foamy bangies oh no boom bang II
okay go we're going I thought I was the
leader here guys ah no oh no no no no
not separated oh okay all right
oh oh this stupid this building was made
by the same guy who made the last
building oh man that is weird
all right I'm moving forward I don't get
any armor in this game feel I just
helped all right hello anybody Oh
loading screen uh okay I'm okay okay I'm
okay guys tough manly markiplier chapter
5 already man I'm blowin through this
game
it looks
okay Oh No I'll bring it on bring it on
bring it on ready I'm ready for you what
do you got what do you got oh boy
don't bring it oh no what is that what
is that oh that's tight Oh No okay
getting out of here Oh what is that what
is that what is it
pyrotechnic locker Oh fire Oh God Oh God
why did my place I'd go out oh oh where
did I come from
oh man Oh open up please you got nowhere
to go go go nowhere I got nowhere to go
oh man why isn't this working
Oh what the is that there that must have
been there I must
I had to be there right right guys
oh man I'm losing it I'm losing it I'm
losing it all flare flare please give me
give me the baby huh okay all right
what is this
well thank you thank goodness
losing it guys I'm losing it not
handling this well
okay button that do Oh
oh oh whoa oh man this is everything
that deadspace wished it could be oh oh
oh how are you still alive yeah get dead
oh all right man I wish I had my
flashlight oh you guys can't see it Oh
what the [ __ ]
oh man I cannot see a thing he's not who
I [ __ ] you get back Oh
get back oh yeah oh you hardcore okay ah
get Oh with an axe Oh didn't standard
pants all right Punk
cannot see a thing what is this buttons
buttons buttons
what by doing okay
okay thank you a light I gotta move
oh oh whoa up pitov they're home thank
goodness oh then I'll get me out of here
get me out of here oh thank you light
finally oh please let me meet up with my
SWAT guys oh man
I'm freaking out guys oh no no no no no
no no no [ __ ] right off
Oh
oh no don't do a countdown Oh screw you
woman oh no no no no oh [ __ ] you oh god
oh man this game knows exactly how to
mess with you all there jeez I'll hire
this guy for a million horror games oh
okay I didn't scare me oh please hire
this guy he is phenomenal everyone
should play this
just just so that they can be scared out
of their minds oh man I think I'm more
scared than I wasn't in any of the
frictional games oh wow wowie wow wow
wow
oh [ __ ] what Oh Gus screw you
Oh okay I'm okay
all right Billy are you there please
talk to me there you are
I know filling that find you around this
area why the area outside of this
hospital okay out of here yes to say her
children watching don't want them to
hear expletives while they're being
scared out of their minds oh oh not you
again oh go away go away what are those
things why are they here huh why are
they all staring at me that is
unsettling
either way Oh No
they all staring at me yeah creepy
creepy creepy creepy Oh where'd this one
go ah [ __ ] you get get me get me out of
here
I don't like you I don't like you I
don't like you I don't like you Oh
Brandt brain I can't swing my axe ha ha
ha okay I can now okay oh oh man Oh
screw those things I'll screw those
things they're just mannequins but man
oh god ah good Oh get away get away get
away get away get away get away
give me Eddie Oh screw you guy can you
get me out of here get me out of here
give me I gotta be gonna be on goodbye
get me yeah oh no good oh don't worry no
more I don't want any more no any more
oh thank you thank goodness oh thank
goodness gracious oh please please get
me out of here over there over there
okay you're pointing me over there are
you even
oh are you some zombie are you some
zombie okay all right
okay to chunk Thank You York oh what did
I do
I just do oh no did I just send him to
you to death what thumbs up thank you
thank you all that's creepy
oh boy okay no no oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy I wonder how many
people actually finish this game oh boy
oh boy oh boy okay axe no axe axe I'm
bringing the axe I'll bring it on I'll
bring it on don't bring it on ah what oh
oh oh what are you Oh bring it oh oh
okay
get away get away go away huh oh you are
you okay you okay buddy you don't look
so good you don't look so good seem to
be losing some blood all right I'm gonna
assume you're you're dead
all right oh wow oh wow oh no no off you
get up again
oh you don't learn your lesson you die
oh don't don't even try it
oh I'm not not in the mood zombies are
not scary
what mannequins are apparently okay
don't don't get up
you're neither I don't even trust the
bottom house anymore
give me there
[Music]
oh I got to cut it here guys I didn't
even notice the time of being scared so
much oh but thank you so much watching I
appreciate it as always
oh man make fun of me in the comments I
don't care this game is terrifying oh
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in part 8 of nightmare
house - bye bye